welcome to this video against sila sign
on ok she launched on here no way I
heard that name from Romania right yep
so let's see John Knight f6 they play
that nowadays I came let's see you know
we're going to do in King's inion I
could play the gruene fault but it seems
like it's going for the fianchetto
anyway usually this is the indication
with an idea three well it's really
taking its time yeah I guess that's the
point right one idea of this this
variation is that I don't have to play
Bishop basics I think there is a point
in playing this memo and then night you
form let's do that ok I could take that
couple of times but science cannot clear
this is any great compensation night h4
might be a move that is something we
reckon with
I have to switch off the phone really
when I start the recordings it's so
annoying I absolutely hate it okay so
let's see how do i do that night a 6
have 96 but I don't like night edge for
you and I th for looks like a problem
yeah maybe take the app but this looks
kind of strange I have to admit okay
what eva is not a real problem i have
Bishop g4 now maybe that is still ok
here Bishop you boys okay he I don't
think he wants me to tell you again that
this costs a little bit more time now
this might be enough compensation be
three looks strange ready isn't see form
isn't see for good here somehow
that looks premature um okay I can also
go Quinn 85 here Brooksie one Queen III
had as the Sun it's more than one idea I
just got night see two maybe yes that's
true yeah I think I have enough
compensation in multiple ways a for rook
c8 and then c4 he is retarding the pawn
immediately that is surprising
mmm let's check though if I take on c3
with the bishop now can I keep it simple
come just take the pawn and have a good
position rook takes us even Bishop b5 so
he has to take with the wind this is
just a way for like very typical em van
Gogh end game and maybe you can trade it
down to a draw but not sure about that
you should a for loop chicks and b3 the
B point is quite dangerous
b3
he's very relaxed about all of that
isn't this beep on strong be too
hmm
be to Bishop d3 maybe this is just about
her wedding but probably not probably
not I have I'm have Bishop b5 Bishop d3
i'm threatening Bishop b5 as I think
winning if he takes it i have rook a1
next and Bishop see to Roxy a des is
overloading the bishop terribly white
resigns yeah those are kind of a bit of
a mysterious game because I think about
here it should be should be a by no
equal or something I don't know I'm not
sure how good it is well the computer
actually says black is already quite a
bit better maybe I don't know I'm not so
experienced in the bengkos structures
but this is definitely good for black
yeah it gives black a clear advantage
immediately and I even missed something
I can go but should be five here that is
quite quite good
and it's kind of move maybe I then he
can take him well okay this is just good
right the the end game is good I could
have taken on a to actually that's even
stronger now ki just went went with the
the simple business which which is just
giving black Ackley edge but not winning
yeah but this is winning the bond is
just just promoting yeah I know he was
very helpful they're not really fighting
against my ideas I'm not really i'm not
sure about this opening but i think this
is this is something that that does
exist but white normally doesn't play
here looked okay though 92 is it's not a
move that I'm sure about but i really i
mean i wanted to do this but i felt that
this is kind of awkward yeah maybe I
still could have done that actually and
then do this leaving his night sorry
this night a little bit of yeah it
doesn't look very threatening anyway
this position most players some don't
advance here but but play Knight c3 and
then we get to get this kind of position
okay well thanks for watching